we came up with a process for generating
an orthonormal basis in the last video
and it wasn't a new discovery it's
called the gram schmidt process but
let's apply that now to some real
examples and and hopefully we'll see
that it's a lot more concrete than it
might have looked in the last video
let's say i have the plane
x1
plus x2
plus x3
plus x3 is equal to zero this is a plane
in r3
so let me just say that let's say that
subspace
v
v is equal to the plane
defined
by
this guy right here x1 plus x2 plus x3
is equal to zero all of the vectors in
the subspace if you take their entries
and you add them up you're going to get
zero so first we need to just any basis
for v so let's see if we could come up
with that so if we subtract x2 and x3
from both sides of this equation we know
that x1
is going to be equal to minus x2
minus x3 or we could say that our
subspace v is equal to the set of all of
the vectors in r3
x1 x2 and x3
that satisfy the equation
was to satisfy the equation let's say
minus
well instead of let me write it this way
let's say that x2
x2 is equal to c1 and x3 is equal to c2
then this equation would be x1 is equal
to
minus c1
minus c2 so if we write it that way then
the subspace v is the set of all the
vectors in r3 such that
c1 times
some vector let me write this way c1
times
let's see x1 is let me write it this way
plus c2 times some other vector
where c1 and c2 are any real numbers so
c1 and c2 are a member of the reals
and so what is x1 x1 is equal to minus
c1 minus c2 so x1 is equal to -1 c1 -1
c2
x2 is just equal to c1 so x2 is equal to
1 times c1 plus 0 times c2
and then x3 is equal to c2 or 0 times c1
plus 1 times c2 so v is essentially the
span of these two vectors all of the
linear combinations of these two vectors
that would represent that plane so let
me write it like this
v
is equal to the span
of the vectors minus 1 1 0
and the vector
minus 1
1 and you can see that these are
linearly independent
right here you can obviously there's no
linear combination of of this guy that
can give you a one over here and there's
no linear combination of this guy
that'll give you a one right there so
this is what v is but what we want the
whole reason why we even why i'm making
this video is to find an orthonormal
basis for v this is just a basis
this these guys right here are just a
basis for v let's find an orthonormal
basis
let's call this vector up here let's
call that v1 and let's call this vector
right here v2 so if we wanted to find
a if we wanted to find an orthonormal
basis for the span of v1 let me write
this down let me define sub-subspace v1
is equal to the span
of just my vector v1 well we saw in the
last video if we just divide v1 by its
length then we'll have and the span of
that vector is going to be a unit vector
and it's going to be the same thing as
the subspace v1 as this line in r3 so
let's do that what is the length of v1
the length of v1
is equal to the square root
the square root of minus 1 squared which
is 1 plus 1 squared which is 1 plus 0
squared which is 0 so it's equal to the
square root of 2.
so let's define some vector u1
is equal to
1 divided by the length of v1 so 1 over
the square root of 2 times v1 times
-110
then the span of v1 is just the same
thing as the span
as the span
of u1 and so this would be an
orthonormal basis just this vector right
here would be an orthonormal basis for
just the span of v1 but we don't want
just the span of v1 we want the span of
v1 and v2 so let me just let me draw it
so right now we have a basis if i just
do u1 i'm not going to actually draw
what this looks like and it looks
something like this
and it span is this entire line in r3 so
it's span is this entire line the span
of just one vector in rn is just going
to be all the scalar multiples of it or
a line in rn
so this right here is a subspace v1
now we have a v2 here which is linearly
independent from this guy which means
it's linearly independent from this guy
because he's just a scaled version of
this guy
so v2 is going to look like maybe look
like that
that is v2 right there this of course
was our u1
what we want to do is we want to define
a sub a subspace
v well it's going to i'll call it v2 for
now it's going to be
v2 is equal to the span
the span of v1 and v2
which is the same thing as the span
anything that's spanned by v1 is also
spanned by u1 as the span of u1
and v2
so we want to see all all everything
that can be generated by linear
combinations of u1 and v2 and obviously
this thing right here is our plane that
we're talking about the span of these
two guys the span of these two guys that
is the whole subspace that we're talking
about in this problem so that is equal
to v
so once we find this if we find an
orthonormal version for this span we're
done
so how can we do that well if i can find
a vector that's orthogonal to all of the
linear combinations of this that if i
add up some linear combination of this
to that vector i can get v2 i can
replace v2 with that vector
so we could call that vector right there
y2
right if i can determine a y2 this y2 is
clearly orthogonal to everything over
here and i can take some vector in v1 in
this line and add it to y2 and i can get
to v2 so a combinations of these guys
are just as good as v2 so this is going
to be equal to the span
of u1
and y
and y2 now what is y2 equal to
well we saw the last video this is just
the projection of v2
this vector right here is the projection
of v2 onto the subspace v1 and how do we
figure out with that and then what would
y2 be y to be v2 minus that
so y2
is equal to v2
minus
the projection of v2 onto v1 or if we
were to actually write it out what is
that going to be equal to
so it's going to be equal to
v2 is this vector right here so it's
minus one
zero one that is v2
v2 minus the projection of v2 onto v1
well the projection of the vector v2
onto the subspace v1 is just v2
is just v2 minus 1 0 1
dotted with the orthonormal basis for v1
the orthonormal basis for v1 is just u1
and we solve for u1 up here so that's
going to be that dotted with 1 over the
square root of 2
times let me do that in yellow actually
just so you can see that this is u1 so
dotting it with u1 so dotting with 1
over the square root of 2
times
minus 1 1 0 i like leaving the 1 over
the square root of 2 out of there just
to keep things simple
all of that divided by actually not
divided by anything
because if we were you know if we were
doing a projection of line it would be
dot you know divided by the dot product
of the orthonormal basis with itself but
its length is one so we don't have that
and we saw that before so actually let
me let me write this a little bit
let me write it a little bit i'll just
move it down let's see if i can move it
so it's just equal to that guy
right v
let me make the numbers clear this is v2
v2
minus the projection of v2 onto the
subspace 1. so that's just v2
v2
dotted with my orthonormal basis for v1
my first vector in my orthonormal basis
there's only one so i'm only going to
have one term here and then all of that
times my orthonormal basis vector for v1
so 1
over the square root of 2 times the
vector minus 1 1
0. now this looks
this looks really fancy this right here
is
our orthonormal basis for the subspace
v1 but what does this simplify to
so this is going to be equal to
remember this right here
this piece right there that's the
projection
onto v1 of v2 that's what that was right
there
so this is going to be equal to the
vector
minus 1 0 1
minus
now if i i could take the 1 over square
root of 2 on the outside actually i
could take both of these onto the
outside so 1 over the square root of 2
times 1 over the square root of 2 is
just going to be 1 over 2
right so this is going to be minus 1
half
times
these guys dotted with each other so
what is let me just write it this way so
what is these guys dotted with each
other it's going to be
just going to be a number minus 1 times
minus 1 is 1 plus 0 times 1 so plus 0
plus 1 times 0 so plus 0. all of that
times well we already used this part of
it so we just have this part left over
times
minus 1 1 and 0. this was the dot
product and well we took and we took the
two scaling factors out when you
multiply them you got a one half so this
is just going to be a 1 which simplifies
things so this is going to be equal to
the vector
minus 1
0 1
minus
1 half times this or we could just write
so
one half times minus one is minus
one-half we have one-half and then we
have zero
and so this is going to be equal to
minus one
minus minus one-half that's plus
one-half so that's going to be just
minus one half
zero minus one half is minus one half
and then one minus zero is just one
so this right here is our vector y two
which is our vector y two and if you
combine u1 right here and y2 we are
spanning our subspace v but we don't
have an orthonormal basis these guys are
orthogonal with respect to each other
but this guy does not have length 1 yet
so to make it equal length 1 let's
replace him let's define another vector
let's define another vector
u2 that's equal to
1 over the length of
y2
1 over the length of y2
times y2
so what is the length of y2 the length
of y2
is equal to the square root of minus of
minus one half squared is one fourth
plus
plus one squared so it's the square root
of what is this one and a half or three
halves
so it's equal to the square root of
three halves
right yeah i have one let me just this
is one half plus one is one and a half
which is three halves so it's equal to
the square root of three halves so if i
define u2
u2 is equal to one over the square root
of three halves or that's the same thing
as the square root
of two-thirds times y two which is this
guy right here
minus one-half minus one-half and one
and i already had to find u1 up here
u1 was right up here i can
let me copy and paste let me actually i
can just
i think i can just move it down
let me just move it down
so i found u1 right here we now have
two vectors
we now have two vectors that are
orthogonal with respect to each other so
if i have the set of u1
and u2
these guys both have length one they're
orthogonal with respect to each other
and they span v so this is an
orthonormal
basis for the plane that we started this
video out with for
v and we're done we have done the gram
schmidt process this is our new our new
these are our new orthonormal basis
vectors